air pollution energy and security and
global warming
fixing these huge problems may seem
impossible but we don't need a miracle
we can save our Earth and clean our air
and we can start right now using the
technology we already have
I'm Mark Jacobson a professor of civil
and environmental engineering at
Stanford University
in this course I'll take you inside my
classroom and share the science and
strategies for building clean renewable
energy and storage for everything
from our transportation system and
electricity infrastructure to our
Industries and businesses
you will learn about the key
Technologies for harnessing the power of
the wind the water and the sun with
storage to meet all our energy needs you
will also learn how to make Power grids
efficient resilient and dependable
anywhere in the world and how to develop
and Implement a road map to transition
your country State Community or business
to 100 clean renewable energy
you don't have to be a scientist or an
engineer
these lessons are for anyone who wants
to understand the latest research about
what works what doesn't and why we'll
explain everything from photovoltaics to
hydroelectricity to wind turbines to
batteries to electrolyzers to heat pumps
and show you why renewable electricity
generation and storage won't just save
our planet
it'll also create new job opportunities
and energy to manufacture whether you
work in business government education or
the nonprofit sector this foundational
course will give you the Practical
knowledge you need to communicate about
those important issues with confidence
transform your organization and
contribute to a healthier planet